the guy that I started with you know
Essence was you know my turnout wifey
she was you know that's what's known in
the game is a turnout wifey that word
and when I heard out her she died it was
three months later
and I had watched her interview
and then after her interview it was
three months later
it was a lot it hit me hard
it's dangerous out there Barry how long
you been doing it 16.
how do you know I'm 23.
do you enjoy it
um actually I'm going to say I do love
what I do because it's my line of work
and it's a way of getting money but this
is not what I want to do for the rest of
my life
what do you want to do I do want to have
a business
and I do want to go back to school and
if I can't conquer a business I will of
course not stupid work this job do this
for the rest of my life I'm going to go
eventually get a job or if I can get in
school where it can get me further then
that's what I would do
but this is not what I want to do for
the rest of my life but this is what
provides for my child and this is what's
getting me where I need to be
I don't have the most support from my
mom I don't have the most support for my
dad
with the support that I do have for my
mom I do take it
who's taking care of your kid
my mom she helps me take care of my kid
when I'm working my mom has my child and
then when I'm not working I take my baby
for at least a month probably the
longest of the shortest is probably two
weeks but I'm not gonna have my baby
knowing what I do because that's not
what I want her to think is okay
eventually you should find out yeah
eventually she finds my baby's very
smart for a three-year-old she's very
smart it scares me she's very
she's very smart and she talks to me in
full sentences and I'd just be like
okay wow she's something else so but
yeah my baby she lets me know like you
need to get your [ __ ] together this is
not no game
it's not just not for play I'm not a
doll
which what kind of role models did you
have as a kid
uh I was in placement growing up and I
did have a few staff that I did look up
to I had two mail staff that I looked up
to their name is Javon and big Ralph and
then I had two female staff their name
is Mama Aura and Mama Rita I looked up
to them
and they taught me how to be a woman and
how to take care of myself
they taught me how to take care of
myself your parents weren't in the
picture when you were younger my mom was
in my picture
in and out she started doing drugs and
stuff like that and doing alcohol she
didn't tell me about the drugs part but
I found out
but my mom was on alcohol doing alcohol
she was on drugs doing PCP
and then
I know that I was with my I ended up
going with my auntie my auntie shell and
when I lived with my auntie shell we
lived in Carson for a minute and then we
ended up going to Temecula
and that's where I lived until I was I
want to say nine years old and there was
this summer where my auntie was trying
to put me back with my mom my auntie my
mom had went to rehab and tried to get
herself together
and my auntie did it illegally where the
court didn't say I can go back to my mom
so when my mom tried to enroll me in
school and I started getting in trouble
acting out because of me not knowing my
emotions they put me back in the system
and they took me from my mom
had to describe your childhood in the
Foster system the Foster system it was
it was some staff that cared and there
was some staff who just really didn't
give a [ __ ] they had favoritism it was
just the system is no place for no kid
and that's what I'm just gonna say
period
system is no place for no kid and to the
parents that do put their kids in the
system now that's no place they need to
take responsibility for their actions
at the end of the day we reap what we
sow what we do is gonna happen to our
kids
and it's just 10 times worse and we just
need to take responsibility and learn
how to talk to them because that's what
I wanted my mom to do my mom didn't talk
to me instead she let the system just
take me all the way
but I just wanted my mom to talk to me
I'm just this helpful helpless little
girl that wanted her mommy but she
didn't get that she don't have her daddy
are you concerned about your daughter
following in your footsteps a little bit
no not at all my baby's very smart
she want to do Sports she always tell me
she want to dance she want to do Sports
and this is a three-year-old you're very
smart too thank you but this is a
three-year-old telling me Mommy I like
dancing I want to go do Sports all the
time I just got her a bike for Christmas
I got her a bike for her a scooter for
her birthday and some clothes and stuff
but for Christmas she just wanted to get
on that bike
she didn't want to do nothing else I
took her to the park and instead of her
running around with all the other kids
she stood on the bike she had that baby
fell four times and still got on the
bike I didn't put her back on she said
no I got it
but this is a three-year-old
you work with him
uh yes I do
but I'm not going to tell you his name
how did you first get introduced to this
um I was 16 years old I a walked from my
placement from Laverne and I made it to
Western and 107th to go meet with my
friend and this guy me he hit the corner
he asked me what I was going going to go
do and I lied I told him I'm gonna go
get some money I'm finna figure it out
he said well I could tell I could help
you and I'm gullible I'm a child
I'm trying to turn up a wall from
placement so I look inside his car
he got a bottle of Remy Martin
of course I'm gonna go with him as a
child because I want to go turn up I
walk from placement my mindset is on
going to have fun
so a lot of girls out here they're like
no that's not what I wanted to do no no
no no [ __ ] that's what you wanted to do
stop playing that's what the [ __ ] you
wanted to do [ __ ] stop playing that's
why a lot of [ __ ] in jail for no
reason because you [ __ ] out here
playing
but I looked at his car I was like yeah
let's go he let me have a few shots and
he put me down on Figueroa on 65th and
fig
and that's where it started
and I was only 16 years old but I never
told him how old I was
I never told him the truth
but when I did tell him the truth he
told me I can't do that because you're a
kid and I respected that
he dropped me off on Crenshaw and
Imperial
over there in that little shopping Mark
by the uh what's that the McDonald's and
stuff over there where the uh what is
the Norms over there now
he dropped me off over there and he told
me call your mom tell her to come get
you or call somebody but I can't deal
with you no more because I don't want to
get in trouble and I respected that and
I let him go about his peace and I went
about mine
but my little young dumbass went right
back to feed
I'm so stupid
do you regret that move going back
getting into prostitution
I don't regret getting back to
prostitution because of what I dealt
with the reason why I got into
prostitution is because the way I was
provided for is not the way I wanted to
I feel like their way out the reason why
well the reason why I started
prostituting is because when I used to
go home to my mom she didn't provide for
me the way she provided for my brothers
and sisters my brothers and sisters are
allowed to act up kick me out the house
and still get whatever they wanted
Jordans iPhones I have a younger sister
she just turned 18 this year she had a
phone before me you know what I'm saying
we're four we're all four years apart
she had a a [ __ ] phone before me like
of course I'm gonna go out and figure
out how to get my own [ __ ] if my mom's
not gonna provide it for me so that's
what I want to go do
and she felt like because I was in
placement that I couldn't do it but I've
been I was feeling that because they
acted up too and they should be in
placement
they shouldn't have it as well so what I
did I AWOL and figured out how to get it
every time everything I wanted because
my mom refused to provide it for me
you're clearly intelligent enough to do
something other than this going to work
I know that's why I'm not going to be
doing this for the rest of my life Mark
I'm not this stupid I talk [ __ ] all day
about these so I'm like y'all be dealing
with these [ __ ] that say oh on a day
of homies how is you a pimp but you
saying on a dead homies a real pimp is a
Gentleman of Leisure either you're gonna
pimp are you gonna gang bang either
you're gonna be a gentleman a leisure
are you gonna be a gang banger what you
you got to choose one you can't be both
when God girls is out there butt naked
you out there to protect her you're not
out there to make it harder for her to
get money
that's that's not pimping that's not
home
and you're supposed to be and she's
supposed to be a representation of you
well if you stand on a dead homies and
you just knocking [ __ ] out for no
reason you can't chop her for knocking a
[ __ ] out for no reason because she sees
what you do and that's what she's doing
you cannot get mad the game has
deteriorated a lot oh yeah my folks he's
not he don't he don't play that [ __ ]
he's some real some real gang
could never
the [ __ ] I see out here I just be like
this is what these females like that's
what they like because I tell them all
the time this is what my folks do just
he don't do that that right there it's
not loud and then [ __ ] be like oh
well my folks this is and that he allows
that well then you don't want to get
nowhere and I could tell because back in
the day they didn't allow that [ __ ] they
used to chop pimps down for doing dumb
[ __ ] like that like that's not a
gentleman you're not a gentleman hopping
out on a [ __ ] and running her down
block from blocking Shane looked at you
and gave her no action
or anything most of these women are out
there with these tennis shoe pins
if you want to say most mark because you
said most
I'm going to say most out of 75 percent
for no reason they're out there the same
reason why the tricks out there because
they trick you know these gang bangers
oh my folks this my folks that you give
him every dollar and all you get is a
few exotic spots you'll get a few heels
a few pumps a few no that's not what you
out there for
even if you got to go through a CPN to
get you something to put your roof over
your head or car do that but I'm gonna
tell you this baby girls
half of these [ __ ] that saying on the
dead homies that's not no pimping that's
not your folks
it's not your folks is it just because
the girls are lonely and they want to
they want a guy in their life
attention do you want the attention male
attention that's attention they some
girls they know they're pretty they know
what they're capable of so they take
advantage
and that's not good all the time because
they make it harder for the girls like
me that's actually trying to get
somewhere
because me I'm a little shy
but sometimes I will get a little Rowdy
but for most of the times I'm shy I'm
just trying to get my money and get out
of the way but I come across people that
think oh how you gonna pull up in a
bucket and say you can upgrade me I'd
rather be on foot
[Music]
[ __ ] using these females used to
choose up with
guys that look that not that looked like
they wouldn't but that was winning
and that's why they chose up because
he's going to help me he's going to put
me in a position to win
I don't want to be with nobody that's
gone
guide me down I don't want to be down
with you I want to get up with you I
don't want to be down I want to be stuck
I've been doing this since I was 16 I'm
23 now I'd have seen a few of the same
guys I'd have been at school with a few
of these guys and I see them out here
and they doing worse than they was doing
when they was in school so it's just for
that point why would I even
fix my my brain
it's you know how it is Mark
tell me about your clients your
customers
um Mike would like specifically as what
they asked for well I mean like what
have you learned about men from from
doing this oh I learned a lot
I learned that man to use you I learned
that men will abuse you I learned a lot
like my some of my customers I'll get in
the car I'll get a good vibe see me if
you can't pick me up and take me back to
where I gotta go it's you're not my
client that's not the type of clientele
I'm looking for this is business I help
you help me
if you if I can't help you help me then
this is this is not a deal
and I feel like
a John should treat a female how he
should treat his own people regardless
of any situation because we are female
and we are still human
okay yeah we are hookers we hope okay I
get whatever y'all call it but we are
still human beings we still have
feelings we still have
emotions
and when the person tried to make us
feel less thin
that's when we go up and I've seen a lot
of girls come up missing because they
didn't tripped or robbed a trick because
if he didn't made her feel less than but
it's like how could you expect me for to
provide you something and you don't want
to give me what I want
I didn't came across a few tricks that I
felt like oh you're gonna give me what I
want I didn't almost have my cut my face
cut off thank God
thank God
I didn't be inside of my eyes
my ex-wifey she had her she had got her
titties done she got her one of her
implants cut out
on fig
so all I can say is be careful you hop
in the car would always be have a weapon
because regardless of a Vibe a trick
will still turn
the trick was still turning like they'll
turn
have you been in love before
in love in love
oh no hell no I only have been in love
with my baby that's the only person I'm
in love with is my baby
I'm scared to be in love with a man
because I don't know how to love a man
because I didn't have my dad there so I
don't know how to love a man so I refuse
I'd rather just keep it business cordial
you help me learn and I help you learn
for right now until I get a little bit
older probably in my 30s then I'll
probably settle down and try to find a
Madman
but once I'm about 25 26 I'm gonna
settle down to get my business and my
schooling going then I'm gonna go into
my 30s and I'm beginning to trying to
find somebody to settle down with
possibly get married but I'm 35 I have
another kid
and live my life on but I don't want to
just be like oh yeah I'm gonna do it I
want to I want to get in love right now
no because I know damn well when I leave
right now I'm gonna go right back to
work
that that's a lie what kind of hours are
you working typically I usually work
when I hear traffic
there's traffic I'm not giving out free
game March
no I'm just uh yeah I'm aware that you
guys work your your asses off
I'll work my ass off I just tell you
that sometimes I feel like I'll write 24
hours because I only sleep for two hours
and I pop back up just because I'm
scared
are drugs a part of your life
uh depends on what you mean what type of
drugs well like crystal meth hell no I
don't do no hard drugs ecstasy nothing
like that hell no I smoke weed and I
take my cray-cray pills and that's it
and I mean and I'm uh
I um I go to a doctor I prescribe these
pills I'm not just taking these pills it
ain't nothing but [ __ ] clonidine
you're one of the sharpest most
self-aware working girls I've
interviewed I think
ain't nothing but clonidine I know
what's wrong with me I got mood swings a
little bit of bipolar anger issues ain't
nothing wrong with that but that's what
the the weed do I smoke the weed when
I'm angry and then the clonidine is when
I'm just having mood swings in the weed
not working I don't know what's wrong
what are your mental
mental health issues
I have anger issues and uh bipolar
depression
it takes a minute I just take overdone
stuff like I had this best friend that I
lost and I kind of feel bad because
something bad happened to her when I
left
she she was older than me she's 35.
and she was really she had the mind of a
three-year-old like literally and she
had seven kids and I just didn't
understand and the stuff that she would
do I'll tell her hey put the water
inside the sink she'd be like oh are you
sure you want me to put the water inside
the sink yes I just said put the water
inside the sink I mean put water inside
the sink are you sure because if the
water go inside the sink she'll try to
argue me down about it like I'm sure I
know I'm telling you to do you got to be
that that little minded and that reminds
me of a child because a child would try
to argue down about something like that
my daughter does that
and I get upset about little stuff like
that because I'm an adult and I'm a
young adult so I and my mindset is a
little bit more bigger than adults my
age so it does tick me off
do you feel like you're on your own
you're all by yourself
I feel like protection wise yeah
you have friends
I have
I could say I have one real friend
my real my one real friend is my best
friend my hair stylist
my everything her name is on Instagram
love me quiche go get your hair done in
Las Vegas I did this though Hair by me
but she taught me how to do it so if you
want to get your hair really slight yeah
let me kiss on Instagram
l-u-v-m-e-k-i-s-h so you're based in
Vegas or here I'm based here in in Vegas
I'm cross country you go back and forth
no I'm cross country you go all over yes
our different cities different for the
game
okay well down south there's more d-boys
or tricks there's really not no white
man that are tricks the white man that
are tricks are the tourist that like go
to Vegas in different places that the
Millionaires and stuff like that they're
just real discreet but down south most
of your tricks you're most of your Johns
are going to be
dim D boys right now right now that's
what's going but you might come across a
couple white men Hispanics I got to you
know but them d-boys are out there
giving a bank right now don't be scared
or drug dealers yeah drug dealers
exactly
you think the streets are where you're
you're meant to be
my favorite streets no you know working
the streets dealing with these kind of
guys Hustlers con artists
yeah I don't deal with con artists We
Them con artists out here I call them um
whole hustlers
yeah I've seen a lot of whole Huskers
last night it's a great term all I can
say is you do not hop out on no [ __ ] in
Chaser three blocks down that is not a
way to represent yourself you guys look
horrible and when you see him on the
street don't do it because you're
definitely not gonna get no action
it don't work that way and I'm not
popping it I'm just letting y'all know
y'all it's
it's not going to work what's more
important to You Love or Money
right now money because I have a child
to provide for
and I love already got the love because
I have heard but but but that was
important because I didn't when I met my
baby daddy I was lost I was young I was
so stupid my baby daddy was a whole
Hustler
you fell for it I feel oh I felt dumb
let me tell you so how dumb I was and
I'm happy I could laugh at myself right
now that's how stupid I was I knew my
baby daddy I chose my baby daddy I knew
him for three months and when I went to
the to the hospital and found out I was
pregnant that's how long I guess how
many months I was pregnant
three months so that mean as soon as he
put his little thing up in me I got
pregnant
and I had only been with him three
months I was three months
I mean we the first week Mark
is he in the child's life
um before he got incarcerated he was he
did a very good job he's not a deadbeat
he did his job
um he did his job so well he tried to
kidnap my baby from me
because he feel like I'm you're not
gonna [ __ ] with no [ __ ] take care of my
baby but it's just like you got to
understand
I'm not going to just deal with anybody
that's
going no just ain't nobody gonna be
around my baby
and
he fought me for two years not like
physically fought me but like over the
phone like no you ain't gonna have her
back because I don't want her around
this specific man this specific man took
care of my baby very well
I'm not I don't say names but he took
care of my baby so well and I just be
like damn you ain't got to be that
stubborn
but I feel like he was trying to protect
her but it was it was all good I just
feel like he shouldn't have been that
stubborn on that on that part
but my baby did get kidnapped for a
little bit for my for my baby daddy and
if you know what I mean by that you'll
know if you have custody of your child
and you do you do have an agreement with
your child's father or whoever you do
let your child's go father are a go
visit you will know that if you made
that agreement okay let's say I let my
dad my my daughter's father goes visit
her dad for two weeks two weeks and
that's it once two weeks in a week pass
that's kidnapped and that's what I let
my daughter's father go do and he kept
her longer and never returned her I
tried to go receive her back and it was
a problem but it was more of them trying
to protect her and that's why DCFS
didn't get involved because I could
understand that I've been in placement
I've been in the system and I know so I
refuse to put DCFS in that because of
that
I know he was just trying to protect her
because he know how
some men are some men are weird some men
will be like oh if you leave your baby
can't leave you gotta pay for me for
your baby to leave but I never been in
that situation thank God but I've heard
that type of stuff
for an outsider or a square who isn't
really familiar with it what do you
think the most misunderstood thing is
about girls that do this kind of work
see me I'm doing this right now because
every time I try to get a job it takes
me at least six months to even get a
response
I recently tried to get a job
I don't like telling people this but
three months ago I stopped for a minute
because my baby and it was hurting me
and I feel like let's see if I could try
again and get somewhere with this
[ __ ] that square [ __ ] like people
keep telling me because I got in trouble
and I didn't want to keep pursuing if
I'm gonna get in trouble and they're
gonna try and take my baby I went to
jail in Louisiana
for some [ __ ] that I had no business I
didn't I wasn't even in the car with the
[ __ ] that I got caught up with and they
was trying to take my baby and I tried
to see if I could change it this way and
because of the other classes I did they
did drop the case and it left me alone
but I did try to get a nine to five and
then they gave me they gave me they
didn't try to they didn't responded to
six months later and I was just like
what
but they were trying to give me a good
position they were trying to give me a
manager position manager's position for
a Solar Company
and I get I got paid I was supposed to I
get paid 2 600 a month plus commission I
would got paid 3 500 and better
every month
but it took forever for the shelter to
get my birth certificate ticket it took
forever for the shelter to get my Social
all that took six months just to come by
to have none of that information I had
my ID but I didn't have my social my
birth certificate it took six months for
me to get my Social my birth certificate
so I just quit and I was like you know
what I've been broke for too long I'm
sitting here selling food stamps
to the man around the corner somewhere
or down the street or wherever he was I
was selling food stamps just to make
sure I could eat and have some more you
know have something
have clothes or whatever because the
shelter only provided so much
after a while I got tired I was like you
know what
I can't do this I know what I'm capable
of doing I know if I go out there and I
go with somebody and I keep
myself right I'm gonna be I'm gonna be
okay I'm gonna be straight
and ever since I've been with this man
I've been straight I had to ask for
nothing right now I'm on auto
my folks don't
babysit me I know how to send the money
I know how to do what I got to do
because I want to get somewhere it's
some [ __ ] that play because they
don't they just playing like what you
want to play for it's like yeah we young
we want to have fun but it's a way to
have fun and it's a way to get somewhere
and have fun
and me I want to get somewhere and have
fun
you have a bank account
actually yes I do but I ain't gonna tell
you what you want to know about Bank
numbers no no I'm just wondering I'm
just wondering
I want to know if you're saving money
actually no I ain't gonna save the money
currently because actually I had to
spend for four thousand dollars to get
myself out of the promoting jail about
like I want to say right before
Thanksgiving
right before Thanksgiving I went to jail
I had a warrant in Pomona had more in
San Bernardino and I had a warrant in
Orange County and I had them once I knew
I had them warrants but I didn't care
about them because I really don't work
out here like that because I know how
these [ __ ] be
so I let them warrants right but I've
been taking care of them I went to the
warrant case and promoted they threw
that [ __ ] out the 21st in San Bernardino
they threw it out I just got to go to
Orange County January 4th I'm pretty
sure they're going to throw it out
because I got a good lawyer and at the
end of the day y'all didn't catch me
catching jumping in no card that wasn't
me
how do you think working the streets has
changed you
always be aware of your surrounding no
matter who pull up on the Block even if
it's it is somebody folks still look
just in case you want to hop out the car
and try to rob you because I was always
taught because my uncle Lawrence he was
pimp and he always say it's okay to be
aware your surrounders but it's not okay
to look a pimp directly in his eyes it
keeps staring you can look you'd be like
okay that's a pimp go but don't just be
like oh that's some Pimpin
[ __ ] what's wrong with you no but it's
okay to be aware of your surroundings
but [ __ ] don't just be looking to pimp
in his [ __ ] face
dude look at your life and realize that
you're doing something that's just so
crazy and dangerous oh every day
sometimes I even don't want to go
outside sometimes and I cry before I go
outside because
I get these feelings like somebody gonna
take my life
and those nights that I do go out and I
feel that way I always get into a bad
date I have to either argue with the
trick or he don't want to give me what I
asked for or either just the night be
bad and it's not because of my mindset
it'd just be like I'm just trying to be
more precautious because at the end of
the day my folks don't go outside and
get the money the way I do he gets his
own money but he don't get it the way I
do
the way he get money all he got to do is
just run they gonna take the product and
that's even if they don't he don't run
they're just gonna take the product and
he gonna be fine they don't weed is not
illegal it's legal so it's like they
can't really do too much
you know so
what was the question again move on how
does this uh lifestyle affect you
emotionally lonely because I don't like
having sex like that anymore because I
can get it any way I want to and enjoy
the way I want to if I need really need
to to be honest
I could find a good trick out there that
want to give me some good dick and pay
me what the [ __ ] I want to be honest I
got a good trick right now he keep
asking me can I [ __ ] you the way I want
to and I give you what you want but
because I have respect for myself no
that's not what I'm looking for
but it does make me feel lonely because
I don't want to get into a relationship
with a man he feel like he's more
stronger than me where he can be a
narcissist I didn't been in some
situations where
you know these Johns feel like they have
more control of you in the bed and they
don't
and they have to realize yeah you spent
your money on me but you still can't
handle me the way you want to because at
the end of the day you got somebody to
go home to not me
this is the business
we're not in love we're not a couple
most of your clients Mary do you think
um
well I'm gonna say uh depending on where
I'm at I depend I want my clients to be
married
I'm looking for something
but you good
they're married they're more in and out
and done
quick money yeah quick money and I don't
have to worry about no problems because
it's like if I report a problem a wife
they're gonna have a problem with their
wife
you're great
having a baby while doing this and not
having
um
not having myself all the way together
yeah I have a place a stable place to
lay my head I stay yeah I have all that
but
at the end of the day I'm not there
every day with my baby to teach her to
walk jumps cops get I taught her yeah I
taught her how to ride a bike her dad
taught her how to walk you know I'm
saying my mom taught her how to speak
I potty trained her but I want to be
there every every step and I feel like
sometimes like
the day before Christmas I almost
thought I wasn't gonna make it
and I sat there and I cried I had to
take the bus because my Uber wasn't
working my folks Uber was work you
trying to send me an Uber way from where
the [ __ ] he was
nobody Ubers was working they didn't
want to go pick me up from the area I
was in because of the gang violence so
you know what I did I put on some
regular clothes I walked towards Hoover
and guess what I did
went all the way on the bus
to my baby house the bus didn't run the
way I was going to come back but
I still made it to my baby that's all
that matter I made it to my baby to see
her open her presents
man I always tell myself and I'll tell
anybody before a working girl I'm a
mother I'm a woman you know I'm a person
I'm a human I have feelings
Chase what would you say is the most
important lesson you've learned in your
life
in this game
or just in life in life in life don't
take [ __ ] for granted
don't take anything for granted
and always be on your be 10 steps ahead
because
today my mom I love her dearly but
she'll always knock me upside the head
and step on my toes regardless
but I still love her
because I know if I need her to provide
me a quick place to stay she's gonna be
like all right you can stay here but
it's not where you're gonna stay forever
like this you could you could lay down
but you can't stay
thank you so much for sharing your story
thank you wish you lots of luck in the
future all right you seen you seem to
have a lot of potential thank you